tiempo para hablar de economía en france
24 para ello contamos con nuestro
compañero jorge hurtado jorge buenas
noches vamos a empezar hablando del
golpe económico que supone esta guerra
para ucraniano así es que el día de hoy
el fondo monetario internacional
advirtió que de continuar este conflicto
extenderse el producto interno bruto de
ucrania podría caer hasta un 35 por
ciento el organismo cita problemas como
la migración masiva y la destrucción de
su capacidad productiva esto por la
invasión rusa es en ese territorio en
estas previsiones siempre se proyectan
varios escenarios el primero en el caso
de que la guerra termine pronto el
organismo punta como un mínimo a una
caída del 10 por ciento del producto
interno bruto pero si la guerra se
prolonga la contracción anual en un
cráneo podría ser de entre el 25 y el 35
por ciento un patrón que ya se ha visto
en guerras recientes como en siria o
yemen el fondo monetario internacional
aprobó la semana pasada un desembolso de
1.400 millones de dólares en ayuda de
emergencia a ucrania mientras que hoy el
banco mundial anunció que colocaría casi
200 millones de dólares en
financiamiento adicional para ucrania
esto como parte de un paquete de 3
millones de dólares que el banco prepara
para este país que se encuentra pues
sumido en una guerra y precisamente el
presidente del banco mundial ha hecho
hoy un llamado a acaparar comida ni
gasolina así davis más basking el
presidente del banco mundial pidió a las
empresas de los ciudadanos que no
acaparen comidas ni combustibles
específicamente pese al alza de los
precios que está provocando esta guerra
el funcionario hizo la petición durante
un encuentro virtual organizado por el
'washington post'
también agregó que las sanciones tendrán
un mayor impacto en la producción
económica mundial asimismo se mostró
algo optimista y dijo que no prevé que
la crisis acabe con la recuperación
mundial y tampoco que reduzca el
producto interno bruto global según y se
prevenga aumento en el suministro de
energía fuera de rusia y ucrania que
ayudarían a contener este aumento de los
precios que ya comienza a afectar
algunos países de áfrica del norte muy
bien y el petróleo precisamente está en
medio de toda esta guerra pero hemos
visto este fin de semana un retroceso en
el precio así en los últimos semanas ha
sido un mercado super volátil el mercado
de los futuros de londres
y el precio del barril de petróleo brent
para entrega en mayo terminó en 106
dólares un 66 por ciento menos que al
finalizar la sesión anterior mientras
que la referencia de texas se ubicó en
102 dólares pese a esta leve caída los
precios del petróleo subieron un 34% en
lo que va de 2022 afectados por la
amenaza de interrupciones en el
suministro del petróleo ruso esta caída
del precio internacional del petróleo se
debe a los posibles avances en las
negociaciones entre rusia y ucrania así
como el confinamiento decretado en la
ciudad de shenzhen un centro tecnológico
al sur de china bueno jorge ampliamos un
poco el foco porque hay más noticias
económicas así es en europa la comisión
de asuntos económicos del parlamento
europeo aprobó la primera propuesta para
todas las cripto divisas en la unión
europea desde su emisión hasta su
supervisión la regulación prevé que los
proveedores de cripto para operar en la
unión europea deben tener presencia
física en el continente así como
informar a los inversores sobre el uso
que harán de sus fondos en china
enfrenta un nuevo brote de kobe 19 que
hizo suspender operaciones a los
proveedores apple toyota y volkswagen
algo que pone más presión a la cadena de
suministro varias ciudades endurecieron
sus políticas para frenar los contagios
entre ellas este centro tecnológico
shenzhen y en francia vemos que no son
imágenes de archivo en francia- de las
personas ya puedan estar sus mascarillas
en estadios museos teatros discotecas
ferias y transporte de larga distancia
francia dispuso que las mascarillas ya
no son obligatorias en interiores en la
mayoría de los lugares públicos y para
acabar vamos con los indicadores de las
principales bolsas mundiales rodrigo
iniciamos con wall street que cerró en
negativo pese a las conversaciones entre
rusia y ucrania
los inversores no lograron mantener la
ganancia del inicio de la sesión en
europa esas expectativas diplomáticas en
torno a la guerra hizo que el dax 40 de
fráncfort cerrará en positivo con un
aumento del 2,21 por ciento y en américa
latina' el índice s&p merval de las
acciones de empresas líderes de la bolsa
de comercio buenos aires cerró con una
caída del
4,54 por ciento a propósito cuando el
senado de argentina inició el
tratamiento en comisiones del acuerdo
alcanzado entre el gobierno y el fondo
monetario interno porque como siempre un
excelente repaso de la actualidad
económica a los espectadores les
invitamos a que sigan conectados en
france24 france24 puntocom
[Música]